hi it's Joe I'm here for the cuddle room
this is not cuddled and spooned by
strangers such as not happy about it I
hate it already this is called ultimate
bucket list we're all gonna choose items
from our bucket list to determine what
belongs on the ultimate bucket list
things that everyone should try to do
before you know they kick the bucket we
are here in America New York City
Rachele choose something on your bucket
list this might be a little bit
controversial but I'm gonna take both of
you to a sound bath oh you were gonna
bathe in some sound lay on a mat and
you're gonna hear all the sounds feel
really Zen it's like wellness wellness
is the theme
I'm not talking about I'm not taking my
clothes nobody wants you do you didn't
order the bubbles I told you that still
wanted a way out I am Dave Imam Boca
this is my vibra bath class and we are
at yes studio I love this kind of stuff
rich won't like it it's just a bit
hippie so now listen to good music I
like sounds like I can't think of
anything bad about it the idea of
someone blowing a trumpet in my ear is
gonna relax me like if I've had a
stressful day like a bit of velcro as
you know I don't like that noise this is
not ultimate bucket list material
there's no bath is there he's worried
about being wet
although okay anyway I know just your
mind
[Music]
Myra bath is a new and unique sound
meditation class I use singing bowls so
shruti box vibe realistic pillows
pillows that have these shakers inside
picture being in the IMAX theatre but
instead of watching like a Hollywood
movie you'll be watching you in the
world
what's the beliefs for example it's the
easiest way to meditate because your
mind is being guided by the frequencies
how often do you have a moment just to
stop the momentum of our lives explore
your inner being afterwards you'll
notice that you'll be listening to more
sounds you become a better listener is
there a safe way you could just push the
pillow to the side and just leave lay on
our backs and I will be putting the
sound pillow on top so my Willy take a
deep breath
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
top topics selling everything uh welcome
back to earth
it's very skeptical the beginning very
skeptical about the whole thoughts
behind it very skeptical net to lie down
but then it did get pretty cool ignited
all of my senses I feel extra chilled
out this weird cushion was like laying
on top of me it was vibrating and then
the singer came in she was singing love
yourself hug yourself that is really
important
I know mine's better I just don't think
Joe or rich even knows what wellness is
touching himself all the time yeah still
feel like there is a chance that I have
been hypnotized but a joke a joke I was
late to my yoga class they were already
calm about it
I preferred some sounds with others I
like the accordion you were releasing a
lot she wasn't meaning what you release
was relaxing time to move on my bucket
list wellness item is a rage label
do you know what it is do you know what
it is it's a room that you go any break
loads of stuff I'd like to smash up a
car no you can't get a car we're talking
like a plate printer I have to smash up
my friends up dude huge you know they've
been the printer does that oh yeah I'm
gonna smash up it's an avocado want to
smash up the concept of rage over smash
up the rocks on the beach it's one of
the worst car journeys in my life my
name is Jeffrey I'm the owner and you're
at the h2 engine so the range gage is a
safe environment where you can de-stress
and have fun by breaking broken
electronics or plates as well oh we got
crowbars and bats like UPS 2's they're
like I would definitely like to have a
ps2 well you guys are gonna be able to
smash one yeah and surprisingly these
are really really durable
there's not a lot of healthy outlets for
people to physically you know let out
their frustrations you know something
exciting and new like breaking things
it's a lot more fun so here we have all
of our items that people come in and
smash monitors dishware slates keyboards
laptops at some game consoles cathartic
is the word we hear a lot or therapeutic
what do people love breaking advice
people love printers most people work in
office jobs the printer is usually a
source of frustration we do get people
coming right after work and they're
coming in like full business suits let
whatever happens naturally everyone goes
through the same process of in beginning
they don't know what they're expecting
and then by the end of that they're
pretty much experts joke should you I
came second in an angry competition I
was quite calm about it that's good the
best luck in - joke for rich to choose
this there must be something wrong with
it
quite proud of myself for choosing this
I think he needs to let off some steam
this is a really off-piste way of taking
care of yourself I don't think I've ever
broken anything intentionally gonna
break a laptop break a printer
definitely they take care of the ps/2
right do you see what I mean I there's
some secret rage in there underneath the
orders are not oh this is a good one
that was really fun
[Music]
[Music]
stationing really hot right not felt
really right have been through a bit of
therapy but now I feel like I'm gonna
have to need therapy to get over that
therapy I think I've realized a matching
quite a gentle person love the sound of
Smashing keyboard PlayStation was like
my least favorite you also notice how
complex these items are you're not gonna
do this in your house
sorry Bill Gates if he watches this give
it pissed I feel like I've released a
lot through the Smashing in all
seriousness times are being stirred in
your vicinity and it's been very
apparent that you've released tension
you versus tink I'm always a bit nervous
when we save your one till the end no
come on I'll give you a clue
I was cuddling we're going to a couple
room it's what you need do we get
touched by a stranger cuddled by a
stranger this is so creepy this is on
your bucket list
I love I want a nice warm cuddle for our
professional cuddler it's not weird I
don't know what's wrong with you babe
you can't no you can't its consenting I
don't concern okay we're not gonna be
judgmental have an open mind
it's gonna be good for your it yeah
hi it's Joe I'm here for the cuddle room
sometimes I feel like I just need a
cuddle
shut up totally out of my comfort zone
just yeah I think we all need love
cuddled and spooned by strangers
it doesn't sound terrible but it doesn't
sound normal
why would anyone choose to do it why
would anyone put it on their bucket list
because I want to mess it up so just
soon I'm not sure about Rach likes to do
alternative things who spoons like you
talked about it I think she's a bit
skeptical and maybe a little bit scared
I called way but the good news is rich
is freaking out way more than I am not
happy about it like I hate it already I
want to cuddle
[Music]
I'm Alan Hashanah Murray Hallet 0cj i'm
Corwin and we are cutting it's a safe
space where you have the opportunity for
touch but it's not actually required how
do you think a just holding hands could
be I gazing it could be spying against
spine they don't have to be spooning I'm
my opt out of the spooning the urinated
you're the one that needs it I really
appreciate that you're coming for one
even though you're scared that shows a
lot of bravery encourage didn't have
much choice but yeah and how long is
this Russian typically yeah typically
they're an hour or sometimes 90 minutes
and communication is vital who really
articulate your actual needs and lots
I've been meaning to to even like be
having those conversations about
boundaries around touch it's a lot of
practice and a screaming receipt me not
taking no personally you get to have a
deeper relationship with yourself I feel
more relaxed talking to you guys I know
and let's just start by connecting
every color okay I have like how do you
typically stop hug like that
how would you like to cuddle but no no
how's that feeling yeah that's that's
fine
how's that feeling yeah that's fine
I call this the papa bear probably more
relaxed
[Music]
it's a kind of mixture therapy of having
a massage this is good look at me the
best thing I've ever seen
anyway how good was that
feel so good off the car door feel very
relaxed he was a lovely guy it's great
therapies now yeah it gives you a lot of
peace I think this shows that you
shouldn't judge something until you do
it my choice is Rachel what raised room
bombs on the ultimate bucket list I'm
all about the cuddles has changed me he
really loves about that baby was amazing
but the cuddle room like surprised me
and I'm going to be a ninja sleeping a
stable chat with a stranger milk a cow
[Music]